all right Alan is with us in Austin
Texas hi Alan how are you I'm doing well
Dave and yourself better than I deserve
how can I help perfect my call is
probably about ten years not soon enough
I've got the your favorite product the
non term insurance Oh life I guess they
permanent whole life yes and trying to
figure out how to get out of it without
losing my whole shirt too late I'm
afraid you were going to say that you're
just going to lose your shirt and your
t-shirt if you stay in it so go ahead
and get out to get out and pull the
band-aid off huh yeah you're not going
to it's not going to get better it's
only gonna get worse and so what what am
i if I pull this money out tax lies
it'll just hit on the growth correct on
the growth above everything you put in
which 90% 90% of whole life policies do
not have growth above what you put in ok
they suck that bad you don't even get
out what you put in so how much is your
premium about a thousand a month oh my
lord
that's what I put in for how long it's
been for 10 so you put 120 thousand
bucks in there
correct and what's the cash value I
surrender value that they're going to
send you a check for I don't have that
in front of me right the second I do not
know is it in excess of 120 thousand yes
yes okay then you'll be taxed on the
amount in excess of that that is your
basis okay your basis is the total of
your premiums paid in but uh anything
over that yes and I don't even like
thinking about it and that's why once
you know if there is an easier way out
of this peg it is not you know if you
back it out and you figure out what you
actually do get out of it above one
hundred and twenty thousand the national
average is 1.2 percent over 10 years so
ten percent give or take I'm going to
guess and say you probably don't have
135 coming out okay but I might be wrong
don't you have to be my homework luckily
we
our debt-free other than and we've
actually got our house paid off so we
are debt-free that's great well you just
take this money and invest it wisely and
you'll be right you know you'll make a
lot more on it and they don't keep it
when you die you know if you got the
money invested mutual funds or something
they don't keep it when you die when
it's invested in whole life policy you
die they keep your money alright and
I've asked that I've asked my age and
dad and he says no we give you
everything plus what's over so now no I
don't know that again they don't give
you the cash value plus the face value
they give you the face value that's it
period huh that's it and that that's
just not correct now yeah well yeah we
give you the 120 plus we'll give you up
to the face value above 120 yeah that
they'll do but the total is still equals
what the face value which still means
what your hundred twenty thousand that
you paid extra to create is gone you
bought insurance and an investment and
you're only going to get the insurance
when you die that's the problem
so yeah you need to get out of that crap
as fast as you can if you need term life
insurance make sure you have that in
place before you cancel any existing
policies that's the proper thing to do
but man get that done yesterday this has
gone on way long enough hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
Oh